[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم مشاهدينا كل عام
وانتم بالف خير نبدا بالعنوان
روسيه
لمهاجمه اراضيها وكيف تسقط عشرات المسيرات
اعتقالات جديده في ايران في اول ايام
السنه الجديده واحكام الاعدام تلاحق
المحتجين
عبره ثلاث مراحل
تضم مسؤولين رئيس المحكمه الاتحاديه
العليا العراقيه يحمل السياسيين مسؤوليه
عدم مكافحه الفساد
بكين وفرنسا تحظوا على فرد قيود على
القادمين من الصين
ايه ده المشاهدين البدايه في الخامسه من
اخر التطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت عن استهداف
مصانع عسكريه اوكرانيه تستخدم لانتاج
المسيرات بصواريخ دقيقه بعيده المدى كما
كشفت عن تدمير مستودعات ومراكز اطلاق
المسيرات الاوكرانيه قالت الدفاع الروسيه
انها افشلت محاولات لكيف للقيام بهاجمات
ضد اراضيها كما اشارت الى انها احبطت
محاولات اوكرانيه للتواغل في جنوب دونتستك
بالمقابل اعلنت اوكرانيا ان دفاعاتها
الجويه اسقطت اثنتين وثلاثين طائره مسيره
روسيه فوق العاصمه كيب ذكرت هيئه الاركان
العامه الاوكرانيه ان روسيا شنت مالا يقل
عن 70 هجوما براجمات الصواريخ على مناطق
مختلفه من اوكرانيا واشارت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه الى التصدي لتواغلات روسيه في
دوناتسك وشرق لوجان
للمزيد افاده مراسل العربيه باستئناف
الجيش الاوكراني عمليات قصف مناطق مدنيه
داخل مقاطعه دوناتسكو ولجان والقذف اسفر
اذا عن مقتل حوالي سبعه قتله واصابه حوالي
10 اخرين القصف استهدف طبعا الاوكراني
مستشفيات واحياء سكنيه ومراكز ثقافيه وبنا
تحتيه في المقاطعتين فيما افادت مصادر
ومحليه باستخدام الجيش الاوكراني حوالي
400 صاروخ ضمن اسلحه غربيه حديثه لم
تستخدم من قبل
المزيد معنى من ثياب مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل ومن دونيتك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر وابدا بك رائد خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالتواهلات من يتوغل في اي منطقه لانه
الاتهامات متبادله بهذا الاطار
طيب
يعني تطورات كبيره في المحور الشرقي
وجنوبي على حد سواء من الازمه الاوكرانيه
وايضا مقاطعه همم من الصواريخ التي
لا تتوقف عن السقوط تستهدف المدنيين
والمناطق السكنيه
بالفعل همم الاحصائيه لل 24 ساعه الماضيه
اكثر همم من 400 صاروخ وقديفه سقطت على
همم مدينه وايضا
هناك صواريخ حديثه العهد لم تستعمل او لم
تستخدم من قبل هكذا يكون المراقبون هنا
هناك حركه نزوح كبيره الاجانب
السلطات المحليه هنا تشهد نزوح معظم سكان
المدينه الى المناطق الاكثر امنا في
الجنوب نحو مريوب وبلغافه ما زال قصف
مستمرا حتى الان ونسمع الاصوات
المتبادل ما بين الطرفين حركه النزوحيه
شامله وليست وحدها ميسون هل تسمعيني
بالفعل حركه النزوح يا شامله عن اعلنت
سلطات منطقه خرسون ايضا طلبت من السكان
النزوح من مدينه انفوكان لان المدينه
تعرضت للقصف ومنقطع من الكهرباء وطلبت من
السكان النزوح الى المناطق المقدمه
الكهربائيه كما ان هناك انقطاع في المياه
بشكل كامل هنا في مدينه منذ خمسه ايام لم
تشهد المدينه
نتحدث عذرا عن اكياف حذيفه الجانب
الاوكراني صحيح استطاع اسقاط مسيرات روسيه
ولكن روسيا في اشاره لافته لها في بيان
اليوم ذكرت انها بالمقابل استهدفت موقع
همم مخصص للطائرات المسيره الاوكرانيه
والكل يقول ان الحرب الان هي حرب هذه
المسيارات كيف تتعاطى كيف وحجم الخسائر ان
كان لدينا معلومات
نعم تحياتي ميسون لك وللزميل رائد في
الحقيقه القصف الذي طال كيف في ال 24 او
ال 48 ساعه في الحقيقه الماضيه يعني كنا
شهود على مواقع المواقع التي طالها القصف
في داخل العاصمه اكيد لم يكن هنالك اصابات
في اي مؤسسه خلاف المناطق السكنيه
والمباني
بالسكان كان هناك ضرر نتيجه شظيه سقطت في
احد المصانع همم هو احد المصانع المتوقفه
عن العمل وكان هنالك ايضا همم الفندق في
وسط العاصمه كيف الذي تضرر بشكل كبير ولكن
هو مجاور لاحد المصالح وهنا سقطت فقط يعني
النوافذ الزجاجيه واتضررت الابواب في هذا
الموقع لذلك لم نرصد هذا بالنسبه
من قبل رانيا همم لما ذكره البيان الروسي
واوكرانيا في العاده لا تنفي ما يذكره اي
بيان روسي ولا ترد بشكل مباشر على يعني اي
همم بيانات من الجانب الروسي ولكنها تصدر
بيانات خاصه بعمليات الاستهداف فعل البيان
الاوكراني من هيئه الاركان المشتركه ومن
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه تحدث
بشكل واضح عن تنفيذ هجوم به 30 صاروخا هذه
الصواريخ استطاع الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
ان يسقط معظم هذه الصواريخ هنالك صاروخ
واحد في داخل العاصمه كيف نفذ وسقط في
منطقه مدنيه في همم يعني منطقه السكانيه
وايضا هنالك منطقه وكنا قد رصدنا من
الموقع وهذا كان نتيجه الظاهريه لهذه
الصواريخ سقطت في تلك المواقع اما عمليات
الاستهداف التي تمت في الليل الامس وصباح
اليوم هي عمليات الزدام بطائرات شاهد 45
طائره منها ثلاثه عشر طائره همم في
المواقع اخرى في اوكرانيا في مناطق اخرى
واثنتين وثلاثين طائره كانت وجهه نحوكيه
واستطاع الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
النقاط التي عرضت في النشره اسمح لي حذيفه
ان انتقل الى رائد للحديث عن سلاح اخر
يستخدم بعيدا عن المسيرات نتحدث عن الطقس
ايضا اعتبر بانه سلاح هل يستخدم رائد من
قبل الجانبين او الجانب الروسي فقط
ما زال معتدلا في هذه المنطقه ليس على شكل
ما هو الطقس في موسكو او في في مناطق
الانفصاليين او الصراع الاربعه ايام تعتبر
دفئا لكن لابد من ان نعرج على المعارك
ميسون بالفعل سالتيني عن التبول الروسي
القوات الروسيه
اطراف
الجنوبيه وايضا سيطرت على نسبه 80% من
مدينه ماركا المتاخمه لمدينه كما انها
تحاول اقتحام مدينه افديتك واعلنت يوم امس
عن سيطرتها على بلده على اطراف
هناك فعلا تقدم للقوات الروسيه حسب
تصريحات السلطات والدفاع ايضا الدفاع
الروسيه قالت بانها بخصوص الهجوم على ثياب
والمدن الاوكرانيه قالت بانها تستهدف
بصواريخ متطوره وعاليه اللقاء اهداف لمواق
عسكريه وادي المنشات اللقاء التي تمد
مصانع السلاح والذخيره وتمد ايضا الكهرباء
لمراكز اصلاح الاليات العسكريه الثقيله
ذلك من اجل منع امدادات عسكريه للمقاتلين
على جبهات هذا هو تصريح الدفاع الروسيه
ميسون وفيما يتعلق ايضا
بامدادات التي تصل الى اوكرانيا انتقل الى
حذيفه للحديث عن هذه النقطه روسيا تستخدم
اسلحه ذكيه يقال بعض الاسلحه جديده على
ساحه المعركه ماذا عن همم اوكرانيا
ومطالبها من الغرب ما بديها بهذا السلاح
نعم يعني هنا لابد ان اذكر رساله اييه ال
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني رزموف الذي التي
وجهها الى سانتا كلوز كما قال ونشر فيها
جميع
الرغبات الجيش الاوكراني وتحدث عن طبيعه
الاسلحه المرغوب فيها من قبل الشركاء
وتحدث عن الدبابات وتحدث عن الطائرات
وايضا عن انظمه الاطلاق الصواريخ وعندما
الدفاع الجوي طبعا اوكرانيا حصلت في
الفتره الاخيره على عدد من انظمه الدفاع
الجوي على همم يعني تاكماس وناس وعدد من
الصواريخ وهي تستخدمها الان في المعارك في
جميع الجبهات ايضا هنا يعني لابد ان اذكر
همم ذكره قبل قليل الرئيس الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكراني هو الذي تحدث عن جبهات
القتال وتحدث تحديدا عن باخذه هي كانت
الجبهه الاعنف والاشرف في على مدى الشهر
ونصفه شهرين الماضيه قال ان الوضع ليس
كارثيا بالنسبه لنا اه بخبط الوضع كارثي
بالنسبه للمدينه نفسها ولكن بالنسبه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه الوضع ليس
كارثه هي قادره حتى هذه اللحظه في صوت
جميع الهجوم في هذه الجبهه وفيلوغاز هنالك
تقدم كما قال الجيش الاوكراني في اتجاه
كريمنا كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه
مراسل العربيه رائد الاكبر شكرا جزيلا لك
ومع بدايه العام الجديد لم يتغير شيء في
الجبهه الشرقيه الاوكرانيه التي تعرف
توترا متصاعدا ومع كل الاخطار التي تواجه
الجنود الاوكرانيين تبقى معنوياتهم عاليه
ويصررون على الاستمرار في قتال الجيش
الروسي حتى النصر بحسب تصريحاتهتهم
الشديد العدوانيه وماكر للغايه من وجهه
نظري لا ينبغي لاحد ان يقلل من شان العدو
يعدون كل انواع المفاجات السيئه كل يوم
التحق ابني بالجيش وتبعته لم استطع البقاء
في المنزل لقد تم تعبئه ابني فتطوعت الوضع
صعب للغايه لديه اصابه في الدماغ وهو
يعالج في مستشفى دنيترو صل الشعوب
والاحتفال اجبر الناس على البحث عن ماوى
وقتل بعضهم
علمتم ان بعض جنودنا قتلوا على خط
المواجهه اليوم كما قتل شخص في كيف ايضا
هذا محزن
كبيره لا يمكن التغاضي عنها هذا هو السبب
في ان ليله راس السنه الجديده حزينه
الترابيه ويحمون استقلال وسلامه كل
اوكراني سيفعلون كل ما في وسعهم ليكون عام
2023 عام سلام وسيرحل كل من جاء الى هنا
بالسلاح في تابوت المجد لاوكرانيا
لاستهدافات الروسيه في اوكرانيا معتبره في
تغريد لها ان الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا
في الساعات الاولى من العام الجديد عمل
الجبان مضيفه ان الولايات المتحده واثقه
تماما من انتصار اوكرانيا في حربها خلال
عام 20 23
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب قال
ان رغباته للعام الجديد تشمل تسويه الحرب
في اوكرانيا على وجه السرعه منتقدا سياسه
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه ومعتبرا انها
تورطت في حرب ادت الى ادم كثير للناس
ولبلدان
وتؤذي كثيرا حقا اعني قتل الكثير من الناس
فيتضر بالكثير من البلدان ناموا ان يتم
تقويم ذلك بسرعه كبيره مع اوكرانيا وروسيا
يجب ان نحصل على ذلك يجب ان تكون لدينا
حدود قويه
الخمسه ولكن بعد قليل
مسؤولون امريكيه يعتبروا رفضه ايران
المتكرر لمقتراحات لاحياء الاتفاق النووي
اغتيال لحدود العوده السريعه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه في ملف
الاحتجاجات المتواصله بايران اصدرت محكمه
ايرانيه في مدينه انو شهر بمقاطعه مازن
داران بايران الحكم على شيان محمدي
بالاعدام ووفقه تغريده نشره الصحه في
هجمات عليه فانا شيان مهدي قد اعتقل في
مدينه وشهر شمالي ايران في الثاني من
اكتوبر من العام الماضي وحكم عليه
بالاعدام وفقا لما نقله هاشمات عليه
الصحفي عن عائلتي
في الاثناء اوقفت السلطات الايرانيه عددا
من لاعبي كره القدم الحاليين وايضا
السابقين خلال حضورهم حفله مختلطه ليله
راس السنه ذكرت وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه ان
من ضمن اللاعبين الموقوفين عناصر تنشط في
انديه رئيسيه في طهران
ولاعبونا سابقون مثلوا المنتخب وذلك في
مدينه دموند شرقي طهران ووجه عدد من لاعبي
كره القدم الحاليين والصادقين مشاكل مع
السلطات وصلت لحد التوقيف احيانا بعدما
ايددوا التحركات الاحتجاجيه
وقد انتقد ممثل للمرشده الايراني في الحرس
الثوري غلام حسين غيبور ما اسماه بصمت
المقربين من النظام في وجه الاحتجاجات
المتواصله في انحاء ايران وقال في تصريحات
لوكاله اسنا الحكوميه قال ان بلاده تتعرض
لحرب مركبه خلال الاحتجاجات الاخيره واصفا
اياه بانها لا تقل اهميه عن محاربه داعش
على حد قوله من جهه اصدر الحرس الثوري
بيانا قلل فيه من اتهامات القيادي تجاه
جنرالات ومسؤولين من الدرجه الاولى
بالوقوف بوجه المرشد عاليه
[تصفيق]
وقد اقر رئيس البرلمان الايراني محمد باقر
قلباب بارتكاب اخطاء في اداره البلاد ودعا
لاصلاح اليه الحكم وقال ان تحديث النظام
الحكم في جميع المجالات امر ضروري كما شدد
على اهميه حل مشاكل الشعب واتخاذ القرار
في الوقت المناسب وتحسين الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه الايرانيين وذلك في
ظل تراجع القدره الشرائيه وانهيار العمله
انا كمان
تحديث نظام الحكم في جميع المجالات ضروره
يجب وضعها على اجنده الدوله والان نعمل
على ايجاد التوافق في الاراء بشان
القرارات الضروريه التي يجب اتخاذها في
هذا التوقيت كما اكدت من البدايه يجب ان
تعطى الاولويه للقضايا الاقتصاديه
وعدد من الشخصيات الايرانيه البارزه
المعارضه للنظام في طهران مشترك على
صفحاتهم في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ذكر
فيها ان عام 20 22 كان عام تضامن
الايرانيين رغم التوجهات المختلفه كما ان
20 23 سيكونوا عاما انتصارا للشعب ولا
تحقيق الحريات والعداله في ايران يذكر ان
من بين المواقعين الى جانب رضا بهلوي في
البيان الممثله نازلين بنيادي واللاعب
السابق علي كريمي والمشطاء حامد اسماعيل
اليوم
وغشيتا فرهاني ومسيح عالي نشاه
وفي الملف النووي في ايران قال مسؤول
امريكيه لموقع جاد ايران المتخصص في
الشؤون الايرانيه قال ان طهران قتلت حظوظ
العوده السريعه الى الاتفاق النووي بسبب
رفضها المتكرر للمقترحات المعروضه عليها
خلال العامين الماضيين مضيفا ان الاداره
الحاليه لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي بينما توصل
ايران توسيعه برنامجها النووي بطرق
استفزازيه كما اوضح المسؤول الامريكيه ان
قرارات الاداره الايرانيه فيما يتعلق بقمع
الاحتجاجات ودعم روسيا في حربها مع
اوكرانيا من شانها عزل النظامي عن الشعب
هذا وقد تعهد وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
الجديد يعاف جالنت بمنع ايران من حيازه
سلاح النووي مشيرا خلال تسلمه مهام منصبه
الى انه سيعمل وفقا لسياسه هجوميه ضد
طموحات ايران المتابعه
المؤسسه الامنيه
فرعها ستجهز الاجابه التي ستسمح للحكومه
الاسرائيليه باتخاد اي قرار بشان كبه
الجهد النووي الايراني
عبود في تصريحات لوكاله الانباء العراقيه
اضاف ان جميع السلطات الاتحاديه مهمتها
الحفاظ على وحده العراق وانه لا يجوز لاي
سلطه اتحاديه ان تنتهج اي سبيل يؤدي الى
عدم تحققه هذه الوحده ونفى رئيس المحكمه
الاتحاديه العليا ان تكون المحكمه تقدمت
باي مقترح بشان تعديل الدستور واشار الى
ان الفساد اعاقه بناء الدوله وانه لن
ينتهي ما لم تتوفر النيه الحقيقيه لدى
السياسيين على حديقه
هذا هو اعلن الجهاز الامن الوطني في
العراق القاء القبض على 94 شخصا من بينهم
ضباط كبار وتجار كانوا متورطين في قضيه
تهريب النفط ومشتقاته بكميات تقدر بحوالي
75 مليون لتر شهريا من ضمن الضباط
الموقوفين مدير عام شرطه الطاقه ومدير
شرطه نفس الشمال ومدير شرطه نفط الوسط
وغيرهم من المسؤولين في القطاع النفطي
اشار بيان الامن الوطني العراقي الى ان
مهمه الضباط والمنتسبين المتورطين هي
تامين الحمايه للمهربين عند سحب النفط
الخام وكذلك تامين حركه الصهاريج مقابله
320,000$ فيكم العمليه
ان عمليه التهريب كانت تتم عبره ثلاث
مراحل من خلال الضباط المتورطين والمنسق
او ما يسمى المندوب والمهربين
مهمه الضباط والمنتسبين المتورطين هي
تامين الحمايه للمهربين عند سحب النفط
الخام وكذلك تامين حركه الصهاريج
ومهمه المندوب هي اصدار البرقيات
والبوجرات الرسميه لحركه الصهاريج
ويتم اصدار البرقيات عبر دفع الاموال او
تصدر باسماء مصانع ومعامله وهميه
هي تسليم الاموال بعد البيع الى المندوب
الذي يسلمها الى الضباط المتورطين وكلا
حسب عمله
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا من البصره مراسل
العربيه
حول هذه العمليه يعني طلعنا على جهه
الميسرين اذا ما صح التعبير لمثل هذه
العمليات الكبيره اللي تهريب ولكن ماذا عن
المهربين انفسهم والتجار
منذ الثاني منه نوفمبر بعدين كشف رئيس
الوزراء محمد الشاعر السوداني سرقه القرن
للمشتقات النفطيه والنفط بدا جهاز الامن
الوطني بالاتصال بهذه العمليه وميسون ليس
في البصره فقط وانما في المحافظات
المجاوره مثل الناصريه ايضا هناك السلطات
الاخرى مثلا هناك همم تسال على يعني اسطح
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ايضا مشاركه همم
رئيس مجلس النواب محمد الحلبوسي ايضا في
وثائق تؤكد بان همم البرلمان العراقي همم
يعني همم جاد في ايضا في مشاركه الحكومه
وايضا الرئاسه الجمهوريه في عمليه التقويم
هذه الشبكات لان الجهاز الامن الوطني كشف
الخطوط كبيره في هذه الجزئيه مثلا
اعداد التي تم القاء القبض عليها اكثر من
90 شخص همم يعني رقم كبير جدا منهم ضباط
وايضا كشف ايضا المراحل التي يتم فيها
سرقه النفط عبر ال الضباط وايضا المندوبين
والمهربين بالاضافه ميسون الى انه
كشف اين يتم سرقه النفط وكيف يعني في هذه
الجزئيه بانتظار جزئيات اخرى للكشف
للجهه التي تساندها هؤلاء المهربين
يعني 75,000,000
شهريا ليس بالرقم القليل
هو الداخلي او انه دول اخرى خارجيه مشاركه
بهذا الموضوع على الاقل انه جهاد من دول
خارجيه مشاركه
بالتاكيد جهاز الامن الوطني كشف بان
السرقات عندما يتم سرقه النفط هو ثقب
انبوب النفط وايضا بناء منازل والتمويه
بمصانع وتهريب النفط الى جهات مجهوله هذا
يؤكد المجهول معناه انه هناك جهات اخرى
خارجيه مرتبطه بعمليه سرقه النفط العراقي
والاقتصاد العراقي وبالتالي الامن الوطني
لن يكتفي بهذه الخطوات بل انه اعلن عن
خطوات اخرى سيتم فيها ملاحقتها هؤلاء
المهربين للكشف عن مواضيع اخرى عن شركه
نفط يمتد من يعني من ال 2019 ولغايه الان
والسلطات تتابع عمليه سرقه النقب بالتالي
ليست كما تحدثت الجهه الداخليه
ميسون هناك عمليات سرقه حدث في الناصريه
ومحافظات اخرى مثل ما تحدث جهاز الامن طيب
ولو كان كونك قرات من خلال البيان انه
جهاد خارجيه ربما تكون مشاركه في هذه
العمليات هل في تنسيق مع دول اخرى او ان
العمليه عراقيه بحث حتى الان ولا زالت في
اطار حدود العراق
تحدث الجهاز الامن الوطني عن هذه الجزئيه
ننتظر جزئيه اخرى لنعرف من هم المشاركون
من الجهات الخارجيه بعمليه سرقه النفط
العراقي الاتيه ما بانه ليس فقط جائزه
الامن الوطني هناك جديه من الحكومه
العراقيه وايضا البرلمان العراقي ورئاسه
الجمهوريه هذه المره السابقات همم
يريد يعني تريد الجهاد الحكوميه والسلطات
العراقيه معرفه نتائج عارف ما كانت هناك
يتحدثون عن سرقه بلا نتائج وهذا الشيء
المهم في عمليه جهاز الامن الوطني
عن ان كان هؤلاء الضباط او غيرهم منتمين
لاي جهات معينه ان كان مسلحه او غير مسلحه
حزبيه او غير حسبيه داخل العراق او لا
والبندوبين وايضا كيف يتم سرقه العراق
شكرا جزيلا لك
في لبنان
عشوائيه داخل مطار بيروت عن اصابه طائرتين
بثقوب ولم تدلي السلطات اللبنانيه بمزيد
من المعلومات حول الحادث لكنها صورا اظهرت
تضرر طائرتين على الاقل
من اداره البحث عن الوفاه استخرج الجثث
وحصل منها على عينات للتعرف على هوياتها
قبل ان يتم دفن الجثث مجددا يذكر ان تنظيم
داعش كان يسيطر على سيره خلال عامين 2015
و2016 قبل ان يتم تحرير المدينه بالكامل
من العناصر الارهابيه
هكذا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه بلينكن دعمه
واشنطن للعمليه السياسيه في السودان حضر
لينكون جميع الاطراف على الانخراط سريعا
في حوار هدف لحل القضايا العالقه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
حيوان الفظ يحرمه سكان مدينه بريطانيا من
مشاهده عروض الالعاب الناريه باحتفالات
راس السنه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه حضرت فرنسا
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي على فرض اجراء
اختبار كورونا للمسافرين القادمين من
الصين
لتقديم المساعدات الضروريه للصين للتعامل
مع زياده الاصابات بفيروس كورونا وذلك
لمساعده المزيد من الناس التغلب على
الجائر
ما ان افرجت السلطات الصينيه عن سكانها
بتخفيف قيود فيروس كورونا حتى وقع سكان
الصين بحصار شبه عالمي
كابوس ما خلفه تفشل فيروس من كوارث عاد
الى ادهان الدول فورا تجدد عدوه الشرسه
التي تصيب الملايين يوميا في الصين لم
تتردد الدول باتخاذ قراراتها وان بدت
متباينه لكنها اجمعت على خوض حرب الاغلاق
او القيود ضد تفشل الفيروس لديها المغرب
منع دخول القادمين من الصين الى اراضيه
سبقته دول في القاره العجوز منها بريطانيا
وفرنسا وايطاليا واسبانيا بفرد قيود على
المسافرين القادمين من الصين تتمثل باظهار
نتيجه فحوصات سلبيه قبل الصعود الى
الطائره كما تردد الذاكره القاسيه
الولايات المتحده وكندا واليابان والهند
وماليزيا لتشترط بدورها فحوصات سلبيات
النتائج على زوار القادمين من الصين بعد
انهاء بكين سياستها صفر قبل
ولاحقا استراليا التي اعلنت عن سريان
قرارها في الخامس من الشهر الحالي وما بدا
لافتا هو عرض المساعده لبكينا الذي تقدمت
به تايوان الساعيه للاستقلال عن الصين بمد
يد المساعده لبكين لمواجهه الارتفاع الحد
بالاصابات بدورها لم تتنازل منظمه الصحه
العالميه عن مطالباتها الحديثه القديمه
للسلطات بكين بمزيد من المعلومات
التفصيليه تحتاجها المنظمه لاجراء تقييم
شامل لمخاطر الفيروس مع مساندتها لاجراءات
الدول التي تهدف لصد الفايروس عن اراضيها
رغم وسط الصين لقرارات تلك الدول
واشتراطاتها بالتمييزيه حنان المصري
العربي
المزيد معنا من بكينا صحفي نادر رانج اهلا
بك سيد نادر بدايه رغم التمديد الصيني
واعتبار ان ما يحدث من قرارات هو تمييزي
بحث الا ان يبدو ان هذه القرارات تتوسع
الى دول جديده وجديده كيف يمكن للصين ان
تتعامل مع هذه التطورات
الصين يعني
عدم وضع الحواجز للتبادل الافراد بين
الصين
حتى الان لم يكن هناك
المتحول المتحولات الجديده للفيروس فهمم
لا تدعي للقلق لذلك وكذلك كثير من الاطباء
او في العالم همم
اكدوا انه ليس بحاجه الى فرض همم يعني همم
القيود على المسافرين
يعني
معروف واستمعنا اليه سابقا حتى قبل ان
تدخل استراليا على الحرب ولكنها تقول بانه
تمييزي
هل تعرف الاسباب لماذا لماذا تميز هذه
الدول الصين دون غيرها في التعاطي مع هذا
الملف
اه طبعا هو بحجه ان الصين هناك زياده
سريعه لعدد الاصابات هو هناك انتشار كبير
ووو عدد
كبير
كبيره يعني
اعتقد هذه الدول يمكن ان نلاحظ يعني هذه
الدول اللي هي نفس الدول التي كانت تتركه
من الصين
يعني قبل اكثر من شهر فقط والان عندما
يعني فتحت الصين
فرض همم على
المسافرين من الصين
حاضر رفع القيود اللي كان مطلوب بحسب ما
فهمت بانه الاطباء كانوا يطالبون بذلك حتى
يستطيع الناس ان يعيشوا حياه طبيعيه
ويتعرضوا لانواع مختلفه من الفيروسات وان
ما قامت به الصين ربما ادار اكثر من انه
افاد ولكن ان ننتقل من نقطه الصفر كوفيد
الى نقطه الانفتاح هذا الا يعطي مجال
للناس فعلا ما ذكرته من اعداد اصابات من
سبب عدد سكان الناس همم ان همم تحافظ ربما
وتحمي نفسها من ان ندخل في ماساه جديده
اليس هذا مبرر بعض الشيء همم حسب التوقع
في العالم حتى في الولايات المتحده
يقولون لا يوجد ليس هناك حاجه لفرده
الفيروس
من الفيروسات
الدول الاخرى في يعني في وقت سابق بالكثير
فلذلك المناعه القطيع لدى حديد والموجوده
وهي النيله همم هذه هذه
الفيروسات قد اصابهم يعني منذ وقت طويل
انما نعم نعم
هو معنوي ليس الا على مستوى سياسي وادي
دبلوماسي او لا في تاثير ايضا على الارض
[موسيقى]
هذه القيود بسبب العوامل السياسيه
دائما والغربيه تريد ان تجد اي فرصه همم
التلوث
وبهذا هدف يعني هناك اكبر من هذا الجانب
همم ولكن اعتقد ان ال- همم الاتجاه العام
للانفتاح همم يعني انتهاء من همم
يعني على همم شيك فلذلك اعتقد لان يستمر
هذه ال همم
نووي تكتيكي مقابل النيتو الاسيوي هي اخر
التهديدات وايضا التهابات التي اطلقها
زعيم كوريا
الزعيم الكوري وجه الدهانات للولايات
المتحده بتشكيل نسخه اسيويه من حلف الناتو
يضم الحلفتين الاساسيتين لها في المنطقه
كوريا الجنوبيه وايضا اليابان كتله عسكريه
مستقبليه يراها كم تهديدا على امن بلاده
لحلها سواء مضاعفه القدرات العسكريه
النوويه منها على وجه التحديد على حد وصفه
الدعوه لزياده في الترسانه النوويه لكوريا
ضمت الانتاج الضخم لاسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
بالاضافه لصواريخ باليسيه جديده عابره
للقارات تنفذ ضربات انتقاميه قرارات تخص
السنه الجديده حدد فيها كم خلال خطابه
امام جلسه اللجنه المركزيه للحزب الحاكم
استراتيجي هو التوجه الرئيسي لبلاده لتتخذ
وضعيه الدفاع ضد ما سماه بمحاولات واشنطن
وسيول لعزل كوريا الشماليه وخنقها الا ان
العام الجديد في كوريا الشماليه يحل مع
تهديدات نوويه جديده ففي حال فشل الوضعيه
الدفاعيه بيوم بيوم ستكون مستعده لاداء
مهمه اخرى غير الدفاعيه على حد وصفكهم
[موسيقى]
والان الى موجزه الخامسه الرياضي مع زياد
شكرا يا ميسون واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
انطلقت اليوم المرحله الاولى من والدكاره
السعوديه والذي يستمر حتى الخامس عشر من
شهر يناير الحالي وتصدر المتسابق الاسباني
كارلوس ساينز فئه السيارات
المركز الاول في ترتيب فئه الدراجات
ويتالف مساره لذكاره السعوديه من اربعه
اشهر مرحله بمسافه تصل الى 8,500 كم
وبمشاركه 450 مركبه في مختلف فئات السباق
وكذلك في مشاركه سائقين من زمان 68 دوله
في الجوله ال 18 من الدوري الانجليزي
الممتاز لكره القدم سيكون تشيلسي على موعد
الليله مع فريق نوتنهام فرص ويحتل تشيلسي
المرتبه التاسعه في المسابقات باربع 24
نقطه فيما ياتي نوتنج هامه في المركز
التاسع عشر ما قبل الاخير بثلاثه عشر نقطه
اخر مباراه بين الفريقين كانت في مسابقه
كاس الاتحاد الانجليزيه وحسمها تشيلسي
بهدفين مقابل لا شيء في العام 2020
تشهد الجوله السابعه عشر من الدوري
الفرنسي لكره القدم الليله مباراه باريس
سان جيرمان مع المضيفه لانسر ويتصدر سان
جيرمن المسابقه باربع انواع واربعين نقطه
في ما ياتي الان في المركز الثاني في 37
نقطه وتعادل الفريقان في مباراه الذهاب
الموسم الماضي بهدف لكل همم
اشتغل بها استني اف سي على فريق نيوكاسل
بهدفين مقابل لا شيء ضمن الدوري الاسترالي
لكره القدم سجل ادم فوندري الهدف الاول
لفريقه في الدقيقه 37 من زمن هذه المباراه
وبعدها باربع دقائق سجل روبرت مارك الهدف
الثاني في هذه النتيجه ارتفع رصيد الى 13
نقطه في المرتبه الخامسه وتجمد رصد يكسل
عند اثنتين 10 نقطه
وتغلب فريق ويسترن يسدني على فريق مكارث
باربعه اهداف من دون مقابل الدقيقه
والسادسه 10 شهدت اولا اهداف اللقاء
لفريقه ويسترن
وبعدها بدقيقتين اضافه
الهدف الثاني لفريقه وفي الشوط الثاني نجح
ويسترا باضافتها الهدفين الثالث والرابع
عن
طريقته 70 ورامي نجران في الدقيقه الثامنه
والثمانين من ركله جزاء بهذا الفوز تقدم
فريق ويسترن سيتي الى المركز الثاني بث 18
وبفارقه نقطه واحده خلف المتصدر فريق
ميلبورنال سيتي
تقدم النصر الى صداره الدوري السعودي لكره
القدم بعد تغلبها على الخليج بهدفا مقابل
لا شيء يضمن الجوله 11 هدفا لقاء الوحيد
سجله اللاعب ابو بكر عند الدقيقه الخامسه
ليصل رصيد النصر الى 26 نقطه وتجمد رصيد
الخليج عند اربع نقاط في المركز الخامس
عشر ما قبل الاخير
للدوري السعودي
ومن جانبه تعادل الهلال الهلال مع ضمك
بهدفين لكل منهما في الاسبوع 11 من الدوري
السعودي لكره القدم الزميله هدى زين الدين
تابعت هذه المباراه وعددات التاليه
ضمك الهلال يحاول قصه شريط اللقاء بهدف
مبكر وادي دفاع دمكيون مرماه من محاوله
خطيره
الدفاع ضمكانه
المحاوله لكن دون تغيير في النتيجه
وكانوا يحاول ان تغير النتيجه من خلال هذه
اللقطه
الاخيره يحولها بنجاح في مرمى ضمك
[تصفيق]
يسعى لادراك التعادل وادي فعل الهلال
يتصدى للتهديد
ناجح في ابعاد هام والكره ما زالت خطره
بالراس واصله لحسون
البليهي موجود حاضر في الكره بعدها بقليل
المعيوف يحمي عرينه من هذه التسديده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بتسجيل الهدف الثاني عن طريق الفيتو
الهلال
يتقدم للمره الثانيه
هدف فريقه الاول
جدا لضمك ضمك يقلص عرضيه خطيره كاد ان
يحرز منها صالح الشهري الهدف الثالث
للكاتبه الزرقاء كره
ت ضمك يكثف من محاولاته نحو مرمى الهلال
قبل ان ينجح عبد العزيز الشهراني في ادراك
التعادل للضيوف
سالم الدوسري يحاول انقاذ الهلال من
التعادل غير ان الدفاع دمك استطاع التصدي
بنجاح للمحاوله
اوه حكم المباراه الصربي سارجان
يوفانوفيتش ينهي المباراه بتعادل الهلال
وضمك بهدفين لكل فريق هدى زين الدين
العربي
[موسيقى]
تمت ازاله الضوابط مع سوفينيا لتنضم الى
اثنتين و20 دوله في الاتحاد الاوروبي
والدول الاخرى في منطقه شنغن تابعه
[موسيقى]
قسمه النبويه لكنهما يفضحان لبعضهم عن
مواقع
اتفاق وقع نهايه الثمانينات من هي هتان
الدوله
[موسيقى]
0 1
وائل افغانستان الان حيث افاده مراسل
العربيه بسقوط حوالي 10
انفجار قرب المطار العسكري في العاصمه
كابول كما اضاف مراسل العربيه بان
الانفجار استهدف نقطه التفتيش تابعه
للشرطه فيما تحدثت وسائل الاعلام عن
اندلاع حريق بالقرب من وزاره الداخليه على
طريق مطار كابول داخليه حركه طالبان اكدت
وقوع قتل وضحايا في الانفجار الذي وقع في
اطراف المطار العسكري في الساعات الاولى
من صباح هذا اليوم
وفي سياق ردود الفعل الغاضبه على قرارات
طالبان المتعلقه بحظ عمل وتعليم النساء
مزق اكاديميه افغاني يدعس اسماعيل مشعل
شهاداته احتجاجا على هذا القرار الاكاديمي
تعهد بمحاربه نظام طالبان حتى لو كلفه
الامر حياته وذلك وفق تصريحاته التي تم
بثها على احدى القنوات الاخباريه الخاصه
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي خلال مقابله
مع وكاله فرانسبريس قال المحاضر المتخصص
في مجال الصحافه منذ اكثر من عقد قال انه
يرفع صوته ويقف الى جانبي اخواته متعهدا
بمواصله الاحتجاج
الى اليمن
الجوع وانعدام سبل للعيش هناك في ظل حكم
مليشيا الحوثي واطلقها حقيقيون وذلك بعد
انتشار فيديوهات على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
لليمنيين ويمنيات وهم يرحمونا على بوابه
احد المطاعم للحصول على وجبات مجانيه
ناشطون حقوقينا حملوا مسؤوليات الازمه
الحاليه لميليشيا الحوثي التي اوصلت
اليمنيين الى الفقر والجوع والعوز بسبب
الفساد والانتهاكات التي ترتكبها
الميليشيا تحذيرات الحقوقيين تزامنت مع
اعلان الامم المتحده ان حوالي 25.5 مليون
يمني يعيشون تحت خط الفقر في حين توقعت
التقرير الدوليه تصاعد الصراع والازمه في
اليمن بسبب عدم التزام ميليش الحوثي
بتجديد الهدنه ما ينذر بمجاعه
اكدت وزاره الداخليه التونسيه ان وحده
البحث في الجرائم الماليه باداره الشرطه
العدليه القت القبض على قياده وعضو سابق
بمكتب تنفيذي لحزب سياسي بتهمه تبييض
اموال ذلك طبعا في اشاره الى حركه النهضه
اوضحت الداخليه التونسيه في بيان لها انها
احتجت القياديه السابق بالنهضه وعدوا
جمعيه نماء تونس عبد الكريم سليمان باذن
من النيابه العموميه الموقوف متهم في قضيه
تبييض اموال فاقت عشرات المليارات وقد
تقرر تجميد حساباته البنكيه
في البرازيل وفي ظل الانقسامات وايضا
الاضطرابات التي تعاني منها السلطه هناك
امل بان ينجح الرئيس المنتخب لولا دا
سيلفا في حل الازمات التي يمر بها الشعب
الا ان صار الرئيس السابق والسونارو
يتربصون بالرئيس المنتخب يتوعدون بالقيام
باعمال العنف اثناء
الدستوريه بعد ساعات قليله من الان وسط
اجراءات امنيه مشدده فبعد نجاحه في
الانتخابات في اكتوبر الماضي يشكك معارضوه
وانصار الرئيس بول سوناروا بنزاهه
الانتخابات وينظمون الاحتجاجات دعينا الى
انقلاب عسكري لمنعه من الوصول الى السلطه
من خلال اعمال التخريب وايضا العنف طبعا
الولايه ليست الولايه الاولى سيلفا بل هي
الثالثه بعد ان امضي عاما ونصف العام في
السجن طبعا بتوهم الفساد والتي تم اسقاط
لاحقا الرئيس المنتخب يواجه واقتصادا
مثقلا بالمصاعب والركود بالتزامن مع
انقسامات حاده في الشارع البرازيلي الا
انه سبق وان استطاع مواجهه متاعب مشابهه
في الماضي نجح في مساعده ملايين
البرازيليين واخراجهم من الفقر وايضا دعم
الاقتصاد
في احدى المدن البريطانيه الغت السلطات
هناك احتفالات الالعاب الناريه ليله راس
السنه حتى لا تخيف حيوان الفضه الذي قرر
الاسترخاء في ميناء المدينه ويعض ظهور هذا
الحيوان امر نادر الحدوث نتابعه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]